[Music]
best-selling author Ellen Hildebrand is
known as the queen of the summer beach
read oh boy is she the majority of her
25 books take place on the island of
Nantucket with a pandemic sweeping much
of the country many readers are
especially drawn to the scape ISM that
her books provide her latest novel is
called twenty-eight summers it's been on
the New York Times bestsellers list for
three weeks now
Ellen hildebrand joins us from her home
in Nantucket good morning to you Ellen
I'm so glad to see you I was reading the
sunday New York Times best section book
section yesterday there you are number
one on the list go you number two this
is the first one of your books that's
going to be made into a movie go you
again go you again Congrats Congrats
thank you so much no I know you got to
be feeling really good okay so let's
talk about Mallory blessing she moves to
Nantucket in her early 20s very similar
to you so I'm wondering do you have a
same time next to your story in your
life too to conduct this kind of affair
I had a really hard time even getting my
fictional characters together every
summer but it was interesting it was
interesting to explore anyway and I do I
do succeed I think but you were inspired
by the movie what was it about the movie
that you thought made such a good book
when you talked about Mallory and Jake
and their journey together well the
movie is very simple in that it was
written as a play so it's only one and a
half
set it's basically all takes place in
the hotel room where the couple in the
movie George and Doris meet and then
there are a few scenes at the restaurant
and you never get to see their other
lives we never meet their spouses their
respective spouses and I thought this is
such interesting rich material for a
novel and so one of the things that I do
in this book is I explore their entire
lives not just the times when they're
together and that's really I think it's
lashes out and reimagined that kind of
special relationship yeah and it is a
special relationship I found myself very
caught up in their relationship even
though they're both married to other
people I also like the device that you
use with every chapter because it is 28
summers you take every year and you
start it with what are we talking about
say in 1995 you said molten chocolate
cake the Unabomber Toy Story what were
we talking about in summer 2015 hotline
bling James Corden the Affordable Care
Act what was your thinking the way you
set it up because I thought that was his
fun to read as it was reading the
characters in the book we are creatures
we're influenced by what's going on
around us we are creatures of our times
and so I was I was very particular about
the things that I included you know I
did exercise fads I did food fads I did
the TV shows and the movies and the
music that defines the year and it was
so much fun I kept going back and
playing and replacing and taking things
out and putting things in the night I
think that is one of the really fun sort
of film montage things in the book that
makes you really visualize the air you
know what else is fun in the book one of
my favorite questions you ask is
monogamy in long marriages and
unrealistic expectation now I have to
say I think it is not an unrealistic
expectation but I sit here before you a
divorced person so note to self make
sure your partner feels the same that's
one thing I have to say so what is your
answer to that question and what are you
raising Ellen so some of them succeed
some of them fail the people who fail
create drama and drama as a novelist
best friend of course but I always put
in one or two marriages like the Paragon
so like Mallory's parents have been
married and very happy for a long time
and her best friend on the I'm tuck-in
is getting married and you can tell
they're going to be together forever so
I always put in the beacon of hope yeah
and I heard Ellen that you picked up a
new reader in your books for the first
time I thought this was very exciting
might be the most important reader of
all you've ever had absolutely so this
past week the most exciting thing one of
the most exciting things in my life has
happened and that is the
I'm gonna cry oh my goodness my daughter
Shelby Hannah started reading my books
and it is a combination of my to my to
like work right it's like my life work
which is my children and my life work
which is my writing and she's on page
200 and she says you're doing a really
good job mom nice plot twist so I'm
feeling you know real profound sense of
synergy and love it
yes nothing is more important I think as
a parent when you're when your kids
think you're doing something great or
that you're cool which is another reason
why Ellen you cannot retire next summer
I heard you're thinking about it you're
thinking about giving up writing you
cannot do that now Shelby wouldn't want
that for you
[Music]
there you go Ellen you look great and
again congratulations thank you
28 summers is on sales I work wherever
you like to buy your books we'll be
right back